agt left scrambling after simon cowell
gets badly injured
it's going to be big it's going to be
entertaining it's going to be
wild it's going to be unpredictable
unpredictable is right
less than 24 hours after talking to me
simon broke his back
in a number of places the 60 year old
was riding his new electric bike similar
to the one seen here on saturday at his
malibu home
when he crashed in his courtyard his
six-year-old son eric saw the accident
simon was rushed to the hospital and
underwent a six-hour surgery
doctors put a metal rod in his back
we're told it's a bad injury
and simon is very lucky he remains in
the hospital but tweeted a thank you to
the medical staff and to his fans
telling them if you buy an electric
trail bike read the manual before you
ride it for the first time
it's going to look different than any
other previous year
the timing of all this is rough
america's got talent is supposed to
start live shows tomorrow night with an
ambitious plan
that would have had the judges moving
all around the universal studios lot to
watch the acts we're going to be in like
golf carts
and probably motorbikes and god knows
what else going from place to place to
place
so how will the show go on well we know
simon won't be on the show this week
kelly clarkson will fill in for him his
fellow judges posed next to his empty
chair on the set yesterday
i miss you simon and get soon
well it's safe to say sofia vergara's
once biggest concern
is now the least of their worries i'm a
bit worried about our hair
we're going to be driving around to
heidi and me
or wear hats sophia will you get a
special then go card or will you request
something special to carry you on
um to carry me around maybe maybe
terry you can carry me and simon
together i got it i got one on each
shoulder that's it
you